IS COOPERATING AND KEEP HIM
HERE.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
JOINING US WITH MORE ARE THE
AUTHORS OF THE BOOK, LET TRUMP
BE TRUMP, THE INSIDE STORY OF
HIS RISE TO THE PRESIDENCY.
FOX NEWS NEW CONTRIBUTOR AND
FORM TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
WAS SAD.
I HAD SEEN AND FOLLOWED CLOSELY
FOR SO MANY MONTHS ALL OF THE
WRONGS AND ALL OF THE BIASES
THAT WERE SO OBVIOUS.
THEN IN THE END, AFTER THE HUGE
REPORT WE GOT.
THEY KEPT THEIR PERSONAL BIASES
AT THE DOOR.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEND A LOT OF
TIME ON.
THIS BECAUSE I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE GOOD STUFF THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
DAVID YOUR TAKE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, AGENT
STRZOK NEEDS TO BE FIRED
IMMEDIATELY.
HE WAS INVOLVED IN THE HILLARY
CLINTON INTERVIEW AND IN HUMA
ABEDIN'S INTERVIEW AND MIKE
FLYNN'S INTERVIEW.
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS HE IS THE
CENTER OF THIS.
HE IS CLEARLY BIASSED AND HATED
THIS PRESIDENT AND STILL DOES TO
THIS DAY.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS HE IS STILL
EMPLOYED BY THE FBI.
DID THE JUDGE WHO SHOULD THE
FISA WARRANT KNOW HE WAS
INVOLVED?
WAS HE INVOLVED WITH LEAKING THE
MANAFORT INFORMATION?
2 YEARS AGO -- THIS
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
2 YEARS IN AUGUST.
HE WAS INVOLVED.
11 DAYS LATER.
WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS A LEAK OF
THE MANAFORT INFORMATION.
THIS IS A VERY BAD GROUP WITHIN
THE FBI THAT HAS GIVEN THEM
THIS.
>> WE ALL KNOW THIS.
WHAT DAVID SAID IS NOTHING THAT
NOT OBVIOUS.
YET TONIGHT PAUL MANAFORT WAS
ORDERED TO JAIL.
THIS GUY DID NOT WORK FOR THE
FBI.
HE WAS NOT BIASSED OR HANDLING
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
ANTI-TRUMP AND EXPOSING HIS
BIASES.
MANAFORT IS GOING TO JAIL.
HE HAS A $10 MILLION BOND.
HOW DO YOU LEVEL THIS OUT IN
YOUR MIND THAT WE'VE GOT SUCH A
GREAT SYSTEM?
>> THE REAL PROBLEM WE HAVE.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
WAS VERY CLEAR ABOUT ONE THING
WHICH THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
REFUSES TO COVER.
HILLARY CLINTON TOOK CLASSIFIED
EMAILS ON AN UNCLASSIFIED SERVER
AND THEY WERE HACKED OR
ACCESSIBLE BY A FOREIGN ENTHIT.
-- ENTITY.
THINK EVERYTHING YOU WANT ABOUT
PAUL MANAFORT.
WE ARE NOT THE BEST OF FRIENDS
BUT THE FACT THAT PAUL MANAFORT
WENT OFF TO JAIL WHEN HILLARY
CLINTON WALKS FREE.
IT SAYS IN THE REPORT SOMEONE
ACCESSED THAT SERVER FROM A
FOREIGN COUNTRY.
WHY IS THAT NOT A CRIMINAL ACT?
>> BECAUSE I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD MAKE A DARN BIT OF
DIFFERENCE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO WILL
PROSECUTE HER?
LET ME GO NOW TO DAVID.
WE HAVE THE WORLD CUP.
THE PRESIDENT HAD A GREAT WEEK.
KIM JONG-UN AGREED TO
DENUCLEARIZATION.
OBAMA SAID I WILL GET THE WORLD
CUP AND I WILL GET THE OLYMPICS
HERE.
HE COULD NOT DO ANYTHING.
>> LOOK, HE HAD A GREAT WEEK.
THE PRESIDENT IT'S ONE OF THE
GREAT WEEKS OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
JOB NUMBERS TODAY UNBELIEVABLE.
LOWEST IN 44 YEARS.
OUR ECONOMY IS HUMMY.
-- HUMMING.
THE PRESIDENT GOT ELECTED
BECAUSE HE SAID JOBS, JOBS, JOBS
BECAUSE HE SAID JOBS, JOBS, JO S
JOBS, AND HE MEANT IT.
A GREAT WEEK ON THE ECONOMIC AND
DEALING WITH NORTH KOREA ON
DENUCLEARIZATION.
THE WORLD CUP, THE GUY WHO USED
TO BE THE HEAD OF THE AMERICAN
WORLD CUP SAID OH BOB, OBAMA
WILL GET THIS NOW.
IN 2016, OH, WE CAN'T HAVE
DONALD TRUMP.
THE CUP WILL NEVER COME HERE.
HE PROVES EVERYBODY WRONG.
>> SO, CORY, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THOSE PEOPLE WHO PREDICTED
NUCLEAR WAR AND THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP DOESN'T KNOW WHAT HE IS
DOING.
ASIDE FROM ALL OF THAT, I WANT
TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
I WILL VEER OFF FOR A SECOND.
HOW DOES THIS GUY FLY BACK AND
FORTH TO SINGAPORE AND DO ALL OF
THE NEGOTIATIONS AND HE IS
WALKING OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY JUST GREETING A
PUNCH OF PRESS PEOPLE AND
ANSWERING PRESS PEOPLE.
ON TOP OF HIS GAME.
HOW DOES HE DO?
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A MACHINE.
I MEAN THAT.
I SPENT THOUSANDS OF HOURS WITH
HIM.
HE NEVER SLEEPS.
HE CONTINUES TO WORK.
THAT'S WHY THE FIRST 18 MONTHS
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION, HE'S
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL.
LOOK AT WHAT HE TALKED ABOUT.
4% GROWTH.
THEY SAID YOU WILL NEVER GET
THERE.
NOW THE FED SAYS 4.8%.
HE NEVER GIVES UP.
WE WALKED OUT AND DID THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH FOX.
I AM SURE THE STAFF SAID DON'T
DO THAT.
DONALD TRUMP IS HIS BEST WHEN HE
IS DONALD TRUMP.
THE BOOK THAT DAVE AND I WROTE
IS WHY HE IS SUCCESSFUL.
HE DOES THINGS OUTSIDE OF THE
NORM.
STAYED UP FOR 25 HOURS STRAIGHT
ON THAT AIRPLANE.
GOT OFF THE PLANE AND KEPT ON
WORKING.
HE DIDN'T GO TO BED FOR A WEEK
LIKE HILLARY CLINTON DID BEFORE
THE DEBATE.
>> SHE WAS IN BED FOR LONGER
THAN THAT.
HE DOESN'T DRINK COFFEE?
>> NO, YOU KNOW DONALD TRUMP.
NO COFFEE.
>> DIET COKES.
>> IT'S RAW ADRENALINE AND DIET
COAX.
-- COKES.
HE WEARS OUT THE STAFF.
>> HE HAS A DIFFERENT GEAR THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE.
INCLUDING THE STAFF.
THIS GUY WORKS 20 HOURS A DAY, 7
DAYS A WEEK.
THAT'S WHY OUR ECONOMY IS
MOVING.
PEOPLE WONDER HOW COULD HE DO SO
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS?
IT'S BECAUSE HE NEVER STOPS.
A SMART AND DILIGENT GUY.
DOING AN INCREDIBLE JOB AS
PRESIDENT.
>> AND NOT ONLY THAT CELEBRATED
HIS BIRTHDAY THIS WEEK TOO.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> JUDGE, THE PRESS NEVER
COMPLAINS THAT THIS PRESIDENT IS
NOT DOING ENOUGH.
THEY COMPLAIN THEY CAN'T KEEP UP
WITH THEM.
A FAR CRY FROM OBAMA WHO DID
NOTHING FOR 8 YEARS.
>> WE USED TO TALK ABOUT 24/7